[موسيقى]
من العربيه احييكم هذه اخبار المساء وفي
عناوينها
[موسيقى]
واعتزمنا مع زياره واشنطن الولايات
المتحده تقدم منظومات
لاول مره الى اوكرانيا
[تصفيق]
حول حظر تعليم الفتيات بالرفط والغرب
يتوعدوها بمزيد من العزله
[موسيقى]
الاضرابات وتقنين الطاقه تغيرني شكل
الاحتفال باعياد الميلاد في اوروبا هذا
العام
[موسيقى]
روسيا نوويه على الطبيعه
فبتطوير وزياده اسلحه الردع النووي اعلن
الرئيس الروسي عن خطط بلاده العسكريه
للعام القادم
وتناكد ان التجهيز القوات النوويه مدعومه
بما يسمى الثالوث النووي وصل الى 91% خطه
بدت وكانها اعلان جديد للسباقي نحو تسلح
النووي بوتن اشعار الى نوع من الضعف لدى
قوته العسكريه مجددا على ان الحرب في
اوكرانيا اعطت القوات الروسيه فرصه لتطوير
وتحديث مهاراتها القتاليه رئيس روسيا اضاف
ان جيشه يؤدي واجبه في اوكرانيا بشجاعه
وثبات في حل المهام الموكلاء اليه
سنستمر في تعزيز القدرات القتاليه
والاستعدادات النوويه ما يمثل ضمانا
لسياده روسيا ووحده اراضيها وبشكل عام
الرد على النووي والتوازن النووي في
العالم وقد تم تجهيز القوات النوويه بنسبه
91 بالمئه وايضا تم تزويد قواتنا بمنظومه
فرط الصوتيه وايضا تم تزويد القوات للمره
الاولى بمنظومه الصواريخ العابره
الروسي وتزويد القوات العسكريه باسلحه
جديده ومطوره
السلاح النوويه الروسيه
عاليتين والعمل جار على تزويد القوات
باسلحه جديده عاليه الكفاءه وتسليحي ثلاثه
افواج بصوارخ من طراز ياريس
النووي روسي وهل سيتم استخدامه كخيار اخير
من طرف الجيش الروسي لتحقيق مكاسب في
اوكرانيا الثالوث النوويه روسي يعتبر اهم
قوه استراتيجيه تشمل الصواريخ البعيده
بعيده المدى وعاليه الدقه والتي تحمل
رؤوسا نوويه مهمتها الرئيسيه تتمحور حول
الردع استراتيجي الشامل في البر والبحر
والجو بالنسبه للبرد تضم والقوات النوويه
البريه من الصاج ثابته الى جانب صواريخ
يارس سوفيتيت الصنع وصواريخ صار عامله
بالوقود السائل يمكنها الدوران حول الارض
عده مرات نجد ايضا في الثالوث النووي قوات
نوويه جويه او قوه نوويه جويه تضم طائرات
استراتيجيه حامله للصواريخ النوويه من نوع
كنجال الفرد الصوتيه والتي تزيد سرعتها 10
اضعاف سرعه الصوت ومداها ثلاثه الاف كيلو
متر وتضم قوه نوويه بحريه تتالف من صواريخ
متعدده ابرزها صاروخ كاليبر المجنح والذي
يمكن تزويده برؤوس نوويه بالاضافه الى
العديد من الغواصات المتطوره
فاهميه الثالوث النووي تكمله في الحفاظ
على معادلات الردع في العالم خصوصا وان
حصه الاسلحه الحديثه في وصلت الى درجه
كبيره وفقا التصريحات الاخيره للرئيس
الروسي حيث ان صواريخ المجنحه في الجيش
الروسي تضاعف 30 مره ليسجل قفزه كبيره في
مجال تزويد القوات المسلحه باسلحه دقيقه
بعيده المدى منذ بدايه الحرب في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا عبر لندن او من لندن
العسكريه والامنيه اهلا بك سيد روبرت
عندما ذكر بوتين في الاشهر الماضيه اول
مره موضوع السلاح النوويه اهتز العالم
هذه المره هل هو كلام
للتخويف فقط ام انه جدي في استخدام السلاح
النووي لو 11
اكس اكس
ان هذه هي خطه الرئيس بوتن هو يريد ان
يبقي الجميع في حاله حيره فيما يخصم
سيفعله او الخطوات التاليه ولكن ما نستطيع
ان نقول له ان الحرب البريه في اوكرانيا
لم تمضي بالاتجاه الذي رغبت به روسيا
الامر استغرق طويلا
والامور كلها عالقه
يجب ان يفعل شيئا معك والذي هي انواع
كثيره من الحيل وحيلته المفضله
هي ان يقدم تشكيله واسعه من التهديدات
وعلينا ان نحضر نحن اي واحده من هذه
الجديه
لم تكن على اهبه الاستعداد لهكذا عمليه
عسكريه ضخمه اجتياح دوله في اوروبا
اليوم
والامر معروفه مده اسبوع بان عمليه الحشد
ابو ثلاثيه نادى بها منذ سبتمبر لم تمضي
على خير ما يرام وهذا اعتراف من قبل بلادي
ميرفت وهذا اعتراف مثير
لانه بذلك وبكل وضوح وقد عبر عن ذلك
بصراحه هو يبحث عن عمليه
اكبر في الدفاعيا وقد قال بين روسيا بحاجه
الى جيش من مليون و500,000 جنديه على
الورق فهي اقل من مليون حتى مع كل
الاحتياط واخوات الاحتياط ولكن بشكل فعال
فقط قدم
بعد ثلاثه اشهر من حلول العام الجديد
روبرت ابقى معي سننتقل الى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
ونطلع على زياره خارجيه هي الاولى منذ بدء
الحرب يقوم بها حاليا الرئيس الاوكراني
بلودمير زينسكي الى واشنطن للقائد جو
بايتن وقبل هذا اللقاء اعلن وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه عن حزمه مساعدات عسكريه جديده
لكيف على راسها انظمه بيتريوس الجويه
اللافت في التوقيت التوقيت هذه الزياره
انها تتزامن مع اعلان بوتين استراتيجيته
العسكريه الجديده للعام المقبل وكان ذلك
قد وصل قبل قليل الى قاعده الجويه في
الولايات المتحده
[موسيقى]
في زياره الى الولايات المتحده سنناقش ملف
تقويه العلاقات بين البلدين وتقويه
القدرات الدفاعيه الخاصه بنا ساناقش ملف
التعاون بين الولايات المتحده واوكرانيا
كما سالقي كلمه في الكونجرس وعدد من
الاجتماعات الثنائيه
[موسيقى]
والامنيه
الاراضي الامريكيه اعلنت امريكا انها
ستعطي اوكرانيا
جديده مجملها يعني تصل الى مليار دولار هل
هذا كان معاذ مسبقا او رد على بوتن اليوم
اوعى تنسوش
اعتقد بانهم ادرك بانهم يجب ان يشاركوا
صواريخ الفكر نظمتها
الدفاعيه الافضل
وهي واحده من الافضل ربما هي الاكثر تقدما
في العالم الدفاعيه
هي كما قلنا منظمات الدفاعيه وصحفيين
يحبون التحدث عنها ولكنها مجرد جزء من
الحزمه هم يعرفون بان امريكا والمانيا
وبريطانيا والتي تقوده الناتو في ذلك ويجب
ان
يبقوا الحياه مستمره في المدن الاوكرانيه
على قدر الامكان خلال الاسابيع على
المقبله او هذه مشكله كبيره جدا الاجابه
عن الثانيه
ويبدو بان هذه الهجوم سيكون كبيره وسياتي
في الشمال وكذلك من الشرق ولهذا طبعا
بحاجه الى منظومه الدفاعيه كبيره جدا
شكرا جزيلا لك انا معي عبر سكايب روبرت
فوكس الباحث في شؤون العسكريه والامنيه من
لندن
وفقا صحيفه بوليتكو فاجتماع بيدن
وزايلنسكي ياخذ بعد تاريخيا
كونه اول لقاء حضوري منذ الحرب سيتم من
خلاله تعزيز الدعم ليكياف سينان قالت
انزلينسكي يقوم بهذه الزياره المفاجئه
والمثيره لواشنطن لحشدي الدعم الامريكي
وللدفاع عن اوكرانيا في المرحله المقبله
لقاء يحتمل ان يعلن بعده او ان يعلن بعده
بعيدا عن حزمه جديده من المساعدات بقيمه
مليارات دولار لاوكرانيا تشمل نظام
بيجريات للدفاعات الجويه المتطوره ستغير
من التطورات الميدانيه الحاصله
في ما يقولوا المسؤولون الامريكيون ان
التسليط الضوء على دعم اداره بيض
لاوكرانيا في هذه المرحله امر بالغ
الاهميه لمواصله كسب التاييد من الحلفاء
الغربيين في اوروبا في ما ينتقدها اخرون
ويصرون على تقليل الدعم لانه ياتي على
حساب الدافعي ضرائب الامريكيين وهي مهمه
قد لا تكون مستحيله امام الرئيس الاوكراني
لاقناع بعض المتشككين او المشككين او على
الاقل قياده الحزب الجمهوري باهميه
استمرار الدعم الامريكي لبلاده خاصه ان لا
امل يلوح لانهاء تلك الحرب قريبا
[موسيقى]
في اخر التطورات الميدانيه التي تم
تسجيلها خلال ال 24 ساعه الاخيره في
اوكرانيا اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
اليوم انها قواتها سيطرت على مرتفعات
وخطوط اماميه جديده في محور دوناتسك كما
قامت بتنفيذ هجمات جويه ثلاثه انفجارات في
كريبوي صاحباتها عمليات محدوده على خط
سفياتو وايضا ضربات جويه في نقاط اخرى
بالمنطقه كما تقوم القوات الروسيه بتوسيع
التحصينات الدفاعيه على ضفه اليسرى لنهر
دانيبر في منطقه خرسون
واشارتنا انه كما تحقيقه تقدم في محوري
بينما دمرت غاره جويه روسيه خزانه للنفط
قربه مقاطعه حركات
وعن خسائر 300 يوم من الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا كشفت كياف عن دمار كبير سببه
القصف الروسي المتواصل على البنى التحتيه
في البلاد حيث قالت بان روسيا او ان روسيا
اطلقت 4700 صاروخا على اوكرانيا وبان نحو
79% عفوا 97% من الاهداف التي
استهدفها الجيش الروسي كانت مدنيه وفقا
لوزاره الخارجيه الاوكرانيه كما اعلنت
الحكومه الاوكرانيه في ذات السياق عن
تسجيل
54.898 جريمه حرب وعدوان وتدمير نحو 114
مرفقا صحيا منذ بدايه الحرب
وتسببت الضربات التي تقول اوكرانيا انها
تستهدف المدنيين بشكل واضح في قطع امدادات
الكهرباء والمياه بصوره متكرره في الاراضي
الاوكرانيه
[موسيقى]
بعباره لنفسر افعالنا لاحد ردت حركه
طالبان على تنديدات الدوليه والغضب
الداخليه من قرار الحركه الاخير في حظر
التعليم الجامعي على الفتيات مؤكده انها
لن تتراجع عن قراراتها تحت اي ضغط وعلى
خلفيه هذا القرار قدما اساتذه الجامعيون
استقالاتهم احتجاجا على القرار فيما منعت
قوات الامن التابعه لطالبان الفتيات اليوم
من دخول الجامعات وعن التنديد الدولي وصف
رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
قرار طالبان بانه خطوه كبيره للوراء وفي
مقالات واشنطن ان الحركه تقود نفسها نحو
مزيدا من العزله الدوليه
عزيزه ابدا لي طالبه جامعيه تدرس في كليه
الطب منعتها طالبان من الذهاب الى الجامعه
تقول ان طموحاتها قد ذهبت ادراج الرياح
كما ذهب الطموحات زميلاتها
ولكن طالبان الان من عدنان
فوق الصف السادس الابتدائي امام الفتيات
الافغانيات للنحو 16 شهرا ما اثار
انتقادات داخليه لم تؤدي الى نتائج ملموسه
ليس لدينا خيار اخر لمواصله الدراسه داخل
البلاد فاذا اردنا الدراسه علينا المغادره
للخارج
[موسيقى]
اثار ادانات دوليه
للتراجع عنه
طالبان تبرر قرارها بانها تنشغل بالب
ته فيما الفتيات الافغانيات غير مقتنعات
بهذه التمريرات لان طالبان على سده الحكم
منظر نحو 16 شهرا وكان يجب عليها ان تتغلب
على هذه المشاكل ايا كانت عبدو نادر
العربيه كابول
هذا وافاد بيانو للخارجيه السعوديه بان
المملكه تعرب عن استغرابها واسفها لقرار
حكومه تصريف الاعمال الافغانيه بمنع
الفتيات من حق التعليم الجامعي وذكر
البيان وان السعوديه تدعو حكومه تصريف
الاعمال الافغانيه للتراجع عن قرار منع
الفتيات من حق التعليم كما تعتبر السعوديه
القرار يتنافى مع اعطاء المراه حقوقها
وفي لقاء مع العربيه رحبت ان ناشطه
الافغانيه في حقوق المراه والتعليم او في
موضوع حقوق المراه والتعليم سداب بيانه
بادانه السعوديه لمنع الفتيات من التعليم
في افغانستان مطالبه دول العالم الاسلامي
او العالم الاسلامي باتخاذه مواقف مماثله
والضغط على سلطات والوقوف مع نساء اللاتي
يطالبنن بابسط حقوقهم
دعوه ل 15
بقرار السعوديه بهذه الادانه واطالب باقي
الدول الاسلاميه ودول العالم ان تتخذ نفس
الموقف لان هذا البلد يحتاج الى وقفه
ونساء افغانستان لسنا بمعزل عن باقي دول
العالم الاسلامي التي يسمح فيها بتعليم
الفتيات فلماذا يتم منع النساء والفتيات
الافغانيات نحن نطالب بالمزيد من الضغط
على السلطات والوقوف مع هؤلاء النساء التي
يطالبنا بابسط حقوقهم ويتم اسكادا
واصواتهم لكنهن مستمراتهم في المطالبه
بحقوقهم الاساسيه والمشروعه وهذه من ابسط
حقوق الانسان وحقوق النساء بكافه الشرائع
والقوانين الدوليه
كنار وما يستخدمه
المانيا منع الفتيات من التعليم في
افغانستان متهمه حكومه طالبان بتدمير
مستقبل هذا البلد بحظر التعليم الجامعي
على نساء واشارت وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه
انا لينا باربوك الى ان طالبان ربما تحاول
جعل نساء غير مرئيات لكن لن تنجح مضيفه ان
العالم يراقب وعلنت باربوك انها قررت طرح
المساله على جدول اعمال مجموعه السبع التي
تتولى المانيا حاليا رئاستها الدوريه
نشاط المساء مستمره وفي سياقها
الانتقال من النهار الى الليل المحتاجون
في ايران يغيرون استراتيجيه التظاهر
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد
في مواجهه الاحتجاجات يعاني منه نظام
الايراني منذ بدايه تلك الاحداث للثلج
القوات الامنيه الايرانيه الى اساليب
قمعيه بدات بالاعتقالات والاختيالات ولن
تنتهي عند الاعدامات التي تكاد فرملاتها
تكون يوميه تشمل محتاجين ومؤيدين
للاحتجاجات كيف الفنانين ولاعبي كره القدم
والمثقفين عزو النظام قابله اسرار كبير من
المحتاجين على مواصله المظاهرات
والاضرابات ضاربين تحديدات النظام هذا
الحائط ليس هدف حسب المحتاجون الايرانيون
لجوا الى اساليب وطرق جديده في الاحتجاجات
لتصعيد وتيره احتجاجاتهم اذا عمدوا الى
تغيير استراتيجيه التظاهر من النهار الى
الليل حيث باتركزون على الفترات المسائيه
للخروج باحتجاجات تملا الشوارع كما هو
الحال في العاصمه طهران
جنازه
حيث خرجت مظاهرات ليليه رددا فيها
المحتاجون امراه حياه حريه وشعار سيسقط
نظام خامنئي هذا العام
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تنضمي ليله
الباحث في الشان الايراني اهلا بك منى
الانتقال للتظاهر من النهار الى الليل
اييي خلفوا استراتيجيه معينه لدى
المتظاهرين ما هي
تحياتي لك وللمشاهدين في نهايه استمرار في
الشوارع هكذا
بالاخص مع استمرار القمع واحتماليه قتل
المتظاهرين بالرصاص الحي او حتى اعتقالهم
كما شفنا يعني في فيديوهات
بالفعل ممكن خففت من هذا الحضور في
الشوارع هذا الانف شديد ولكن عندما يكون
احتجاجات ليليه من البيوت
سيؤثر على النظام بشكل انه لا يستطيعون
بالفعل الهجوم على كل هذه المنازل المحتجه
ايضا القمع سيكون اصعب بكثير كما انه همم
لا يستطيع ان يدخلون باسلحه ويقتلون الناس
في البيوت اللهم لا حتى هذه لحظه ما
عملوها لذلك بدل ما يوقفون
الاحتجاجات تماما هذه من اساليب البديله
لاستمرار الاحتجاجات من المفروض يعني
احتجاجات تستمر حتى ولو كانت اشكال مختلفه
يعني مثلا ما شاهدت بدل ما يكون مثلا
اقتصامات في الاسواق بشكل مستمر لانه
بالنهايه ناس محتاجه تشتري حاجاتها ولكن
كانوا يعملونها ثلاثه ايام يوقفون ممكن
يعملونها ثلاث ايام اخر يعني اي
استراتيجيات من اجل ان يجمعون قواهم مره
ثانيه وايضا يستطيعون ان يجلبون مزيد من
الناس كثير مثلا من الناس اللي يطلقون
شعارات في منهم كبيرين بالسن ما يستطيعون
ان يروحون الى الشوارع الناس اللي لديهم
احتياجات الخاصه كانوا منظمين لهذه
الاحتجاجات ولكن الان من خلال الاطلاق
الشعارات من البيوت يمكننهم استمرار هذه
الاحتجاجات المشاركه فيها يعني خبره
وبمراقبه باقي الاحتجاجات سواء بالربيع
العربي او غيرها من الدول حول العالم همم
الاعدامات واسلوب النظام الايراني بتصفيه
المحتاجين او اعتقالهم الى اي مدى سيتمكن
هؤلاء من الصمود بوجهه همم هذا قتل
المتعمد الذي يمارس النظام
[موسيقى]
طريقه دمويه الاعدامات والالاف خلال سنوات
المتتاتيه كل هذه الاحتجاجات كان في
اعدامات والقتل لو كانت والفعل هذه
الاعدامات كانت تنجح بان تسيطر على الشعوب
بشكل كامل لما خرجت الانهار هذه
الاحتجاجات احنا لدينا تجارب سابقه يعني
الاحتجاجات السابقه كانت كذلك الاعداد
الناس
[موسيقى]
السابقه
ابقي معي لو سمحتي فقد اعلنت وزاره
الخزانه الامريكيه فرض عقوبات جديده ضد
ايران وتشمل حزمه العقوبات ثلاثه من قاده
الحرس الثوري والبسيج مسؤولين عن قمع
الاحتجاجات خاصه في كردستان ايران اضافه
الى المدعي العام في طهران محمد منتظري
بسببي محاكمات المحتاجين عودوا الى ضيفته
همم معي الان السيده منى من بروكسيل هل
هذا ينفع هل بامكان المجتمع الدولي اي
يساعد المتظاهرين على الارض اما ان الامن
المعركه هي معركه الايرانيين فقط
بالاساسيه معركه ايرانيه ولكن انا لا اريد
ان اتكلم كملوبي الجمهوريه الاسلاميه في
الدول الغربيه التي كانت تقول من يجب ان
لا يتدخلوا على عكس من ذلك كل هذه الحركات
لصالح الشعب يعني في النهايه في
الاحتجاجات السابقه عندما كان شعب محتاج
احنا كنا نرى مثلا همم الاداره
الديمقراطيه اوباما كان يعمل جمهور
الاسلام عندما تكون شاب محتاج كانوا
يقدمون للاجهزه الشرطه والامن
منع ال- يعني ادوات القمع لذلك هذه
التصرفات اذا لا يساعد على اسقاط النظام
ولكن لا يساعدهم على الاستمرار ولذلك مهم
جدا القليل عدم دعمهم وعدم مساعد جمهوريه
اسلاميه
بالباحثه في شان الايراني
نبقى في ملفات ايران حيث اظهرت بيانات
الشحن ان عشرات سفن تجاريه المحمله
بالحبوب والسكر عالقه قباله الموانئ
الايرانيه بعد تاخرها لاسابيع اذ تعطل اذا
تعطل مشكلات الدفع تدفق البضائع الى
البلاد ما يفاقم الازمه التي تعيشها ايران
ايران
ضد السلطات وازمه اقتصاديه خانقه تضرب
البلاد النظام المالي على جفل نيمار ان لم
يكن انهار فعلا عشرات السفن التجاريه
المحمله بالمواد الغذائيه عالقه قباله
الموانئ الايرانيه بعد تاخرها لاسابيع
مشكله الدفع تعطل تدفق البضائع
البيانات اظهرت عدم قدره السفن على تفريغ
شحنتها ما لا يقل عن اربعين ناقله سائبه
عالقه خارجه من اي بندر الخميني وبندر
عباس وهما من الموانئ الايرانيه الرئيسيه
منظمه الموانئ والملاحه البحريه الايرانيه
قالت ان نحو 37 سفينه تحمل مليونين ومئتين
من الفضائع لم تتمكن من تفريغ حمولاتها
بسبب عوائق خاصه بالمستندات والسداد
بالعمله الصعبه القوى الغربيه اعفت الموا
ضد الغذائيه من عقوباتها المفروضه على
ايران بسبب برنامجها النووي لكن تاثير
العقوبات على النظام المالي الايراني جعل
تسديد ايران لمدفوعتها للشركات الدوليه
امرا معقدا
ويمثل الامن الغذائي اولويه بالنسبه
لايران ازاله الحاجه الى الواردات
الغذائيه بسبب الجفاف الذي اضر بانتاج
الغذاء المحلي لموسمين متتاليين لكن
استمرار الازمه السياسيه الخانقه يجعل
النظام عاجزا عن توفير اساسيه الحياه ما
يهدد بسقوطه وفق خبراء بلال البوجدين
العربيه
[موسيقى]
قال وزير القوات المسلحه البريطانيه في
لقاء خاص مع العربيه الى تحالف الدولي
الذي يعمل في المنطقه سيستمر معتبرا ان
محاولات ايراني دعم من الشات الحوثي في
اليمن ستتلاشى وفق تعبيره
الدوليه
ايران لدعم الحوثيين ستتلاشى وكما نتوقع
هناك الكثير من الاساليب المبتكره لجمع
الادله الاستخباراتيه واساليب المراقبه من
اجل خفض احتماليه ايصال الاسلحه ووقف كل
السفن بريطانيا والحلفاء على اهبه
الاستعداد دائما لتقديم عمل افضل لعرقله
وصول هذه الشحنات الى الحوثيين
واضاف ان هناك مشكلات او عفوا واضاف ان
هناك مجالات كثيره للتعاون بين بريطانيا
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه مشيرا الى ان
لبلاده والرياض رؤيه مشتركه لامن المنطقه
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه عملنا على
اشياء كثيره عبر سنوات طويله ومجلات اخرى
التكنولوجيا الجديده التي نسائيه اليها
انها رؤيه مشتركه لامن المنطقه ومتطلبتها
وكيف بامكان السعوديه وبريطانيا العمل من
اجل تحقيقها
[موسيقى]
في مقابله خاصه مع العربيه قالعه علي عبد
الكريم ابن عمي عبد الله السنوسي والمسؤول
عن ملف سجناء السياسيين من نظام السابق
قال انهم لا يستطيعون تاكيد تسليم
السالوسلي واشنطن وان حكومه تدببه وعددهم
بعدم تسليمه لكنه اكد ان قبيلته والتي تعد
من كبر القبائل الليبيه تتواعد حكومه
الدبابه في حاله تسليم السنوسي الى واشنطن
نحن اتصلنا بكل الجهات
السياسيه او القانونيه يعني في الايام
السابقه امن وزاره العدل الى النائب العام
الى مقر سجنه ونستطيع ان نركب نحن ااا
ساورنا مع الحكومه ومع الاخيبه اكثر من
مره وكانوا يعطون في وعود بان الرجل لا
يتم تسليمه وانه هو احنا طالبنا اطلاق
صراحه للاخرين لانه يعاني امراض مستعطيه
وعدونا وعود ولكن هذه الوعود لم تتحقق
منها شيئا لحد الان
اولا الحاجه احنا بدنا نتظاهر سلميه
وبطالب بعدم التسليم
واا ربما لكل حادث الحديث عندما يتم همم
نتيقا بان الاستلام تم عند ذلك انا لا
استطيع
خيار كل خيارات موجوده لكنها راح خيارات
قانونيه وتلميه
ونحن لا ندعو الى اي ان ليبيا لا تتحمل
مزيدا من
الاحتقان والانسداد الى اخره
سبق ان تم اغلاق النار ولكن احنا لا ندعو
الى التصعيد العنف او تصعيد اي هذا المياه
هي مصدر الحياه ونحن مع الحياه ليس مع
الموت ومع الاهانه ومع
الامور الاخرى
نحن
الاقل
الى التحاور وندعو الى الظهر الشعبي
والقانوني همم لعدم همم همم تسليم اي
مواطن ليبي لجهه اجنبيه
وننتقل الى هذه الصور المباشره من البيت
الابيض بواشنطن والاستعدادات للوصول
الرئيس الاوكراني فلودو ميرسي قبل لقائه
النظيره الامريكي جوبايزن في البيت الابيض
هي زياره الاولى للرئيس الاوكراني منذ بدا
الحرب وحتى قبل ان يصل الى امريكا كانت
همم هناك انباء عن الرزبه دفاعيه ضخمه همم
وعن تعزيز ال همم
الرزنا دفاعيه الامريكيه لاوكرانيا هذه
لحظات وصوله او وصوله ااه نرى انه وصل الى
قاعده انجويز اعتقد سانتوس في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه همم في ضواحي واشنطن
همم وصل ويبدا ان نحافظ على بدلته
العسكريه التي تتميز بها منذ بدا الحرب
وهذه الاستعدادات في البيت الابيض لوصوله
ايضا الروزما دفاعيه مهمه من بينها منظومه
بيترييت ستقدمها الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لاوكرانيا
وتتابعونا في نشره المساء
تتراجع الى ادنى مستوياتها في عمله
[موسيقى]
احييكم من جديد ومتابعون نشره المساء
تستمر ثروه الى الماس بتراجع وذلك بعد ان
فقد ان نصيبه كاغنى رجل في العالم الاسبوع
الماضي
وهبطت ثروه ماسك بسبعه مليارات و700 مليون
دولار يوم امس نتيجه تراجع عن حادث في سعر
اسهم شركه تسلا لتصل ثروته الى ادنى
مستوياتها في عامين وحسب احصاءات بلغت
القيمه الحاليه
لثروه ماسك
148 مليار دولار فقط
[موسيقى]
في بريطانيا اسوا ازمه اضرابات تشهدها
قطاعات عده في البلاد ابرزها قطع النقل
والصحه والسما خوف حكومه ريشي سوناك من
عدم القدره على احتواء الوضع وبدات طواقيم
فرق الاسعاف الاضراب عن العمل يتسع الخلاف
مع الحكومه بشان رفضها زياده الاجور بعد
اضرابات الممرضين الاخيره
النقابات التي تمثل كلا من ممرضات الخدمه
الصحيه الوطنيه
الاسعاف هددت بتنفيذ مزيد من الاضطرابات
في العام الجديد ما دفع مسؤوليه الرعايه
الصحيه الى التحذير من اجهاد النظام الصحي
يعاني بالفعل ازمه كبيره في السنوات
الاخيره هذا وتوعد عمال سكك الحديديه
وشلطه مراقبه الجوازات بايضا بافساد عطله
الاعياد
في ظل رفض الحكومه قبول المطالب المتعلقه
بالاجور
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اذا حتى في عمومي اوروبا اعياد الميلاد او
عيد الميلاد لن تكون او لن يكون كسابق
سابقاته مع شبح الاضرابات المتواصله وازمه
الطاقه التي باتت المشكله الرئيسيه الذي
يقرا يقرق المسؤولين في البلاد في
بريطانيا الاضرابات تتصاعد وتيرتها بسبب
تراجع المستوى المعيشي وانخفاض الاجور
وتدهور القدره الشرائيه والارتفاع الشديد
في اسعار الغذاء والطاقه وفقا صحيفه
جارديان الاضرابات خلفت وراءها قلقا
حقيقيا بنسبه للمسؤولين البريطانيين
اما في فرنسا والمانيا ازمه الطاقه تشتد
قبيل احتفالات عيد الميلاد حيث تمت دعوه
المواطنين للتقليل من مراسيم الاحتفالات
باعياد الميلاد وضروره ترشيد استغلال
الطاقه خصوصا وان بعض المدن الفرنسيه بدات
تسجل بعض الانقطاعات في شبكه الكهرباء
كما ان بلجيكا هي الاخرى تشهد موجه من
الاحتجاجات او موجه من الاحتجاجات بسبب
التدابير الاخيره التي دعت اليها الحكومه
بخصوص ترشيد استهلاك الطاقه بالتزامن مع
اعياد الميلاد وراس السنه
فرحه الفرنسيين في استقبال عيد الميلاد
هذا العام تعاكرها ازمه الطاقه فبينما
كانت اضواء الزنا سابقا تملا الشوارع في
كل مكان باتت الاولويه اليوم لتوفير
الطاقه هنا في جده
اصبحت اضواء الزينه التي تكسو 400 شجره
تطفئ قبل حوالي ساعتين من موعدها اليوم
وتنزع قبل اسبوع من موعدها المعتاد الهدف
هو تخفيض استهلاك الطاقه هذه السنه بما
يعادل اكثر من 40%
وفي ايه
يمكننا تحمل قطع الكهرباء ساعتين يوميا في
البيوت لكن ليست التخلي عن اضواء الزينه
هنا هذا الاجراء الهادف للحد من استهلاك
الطاقه خلال فتره الاعياد لا يقتصر على
العاصمه بل يمتد الى بقيه المدن الفرنسيه
مرسيليا مثلا اعتمدت اضواء زينه قليله
التكلفه وصديقه للبيئه
بالنجوم فالاضاءه تنعكس عليهما نحتاج الى
صنع الاحلام في الحياه لكن هناك من يحاول
تحطيمها لم تغرب مظاهر الاحتفال بعيد
الميلاد عن شوارع المدن الفرنسيه لكنها
تاثرت بشكل كبير في القرى الصغيره التي
اضطرت في معظم الحالات للتخلي عنها كليا
او استبدالها باناده الشوارع زينه عادي
العربيه باريس
تنضم الينا من بنين
ومن باريس حسين قنيبر ومن لندن مصطفى زارو
ابدا مع زميل زارو لان الاضرابات على
وجهها هذه الايام في بريطانيا اليوم اضراب
الاسعاف يعني مثلا اذا اي شخص شعره بيتوعك
وطلب الاامبلنس لن ياتي
يمكن ان تعرض حياتها للخطر سيتم الاستجابه
للاتصال الهاتفي لها مثل ما قال وزير
الصحه وايضا نقابه همم اطقم الاسعاف حيث
اتواجد وهو المقر الرئيسي
لخدمات الاسعاف هذه الفئه الاولى مثلا
بالنسبه لسكته قلبيه بالاضافه هناك مشاعل
ايضا ونقابات معينه همم وافقت على
الاستجابه للفئه الثانيه تشمل بعض همم
مثلا همم وجع والم في الصدر همم مثلا يمكن
الاستجابه لهذه الحالات التي ربما يعني
همم ستكون خطره جدا على صحه المتصل
وبالتالي همم هناك
محدده فقط لكن عندما اتيت الى هنا لا حط
عشرات همم سيارات الاسعاف همم في في على
جانب الطرقات وايضا هذا الخط يا هؤلاء
المحتاجين حتى الساعه همم يعني 12 متصف
همم الليله وهو موعد انتهاء الاضراب اليوم
لكن هناك اضراب اخر لاطقم الاسعاف الثامن
والعشرين من الشهر الحالي واذا ما لاحظتم
اصوات ابواب سيارات هذا اشاره الى دعم
هؤلاء المحتجين الذين يطالبون بزياده
الاجور وايضا تحسين ظروف عملهم او لا شك
انه يعني هم ممتنون انك تنقل اوجعهم
للاعلام رغم انه اعلام عربي همم لن يؤثر
في الشارع عن بريطاني بشكل مباشر ابقى معي
لو سمحت وعذرا للوقوف في البرد والسقعه
انتقل الى الزميل قنيبر تحت المطر في
باريس جميله باريس بزينه عيد الميلاد من
اجمل المدن راح اقول بريطانيا ولكن
الاضواء مضويه هذا العيد
نعم ريما مساء الخير كما تشاهدين اضاءه
الشانزليزي لم تتغير من حيث جماليه هذه
الاضاءه لكن كميه الطاقه المستهلكه خفضت
دون ان يؤثر ذلك على النوعيه على مدى
اربعه كيلو مترات هناك 400 شجره مضاءه
لكنها ستبقى مضاءه حتى ما قبل منتصف الليل
بربع ساعه اي حتى الثانيه عشر الا ربع
ليلا وليس حتى الثانيه فجرا كما كان الوضع
في الاعوام السابقه لن تبقى مضاءه حتى
التاسع من الشهر المقبل انما فقط حتى
الثاني من الشهر المقبل بدات الاضاءه في
العشرين من تشرين الثاني نظام الماضي
وستبقى حتى الثاني من يناير كانون الثاني
اي سته اسابيع فقط بدلا من سبعه اسابيع
وايضا عند 10 الا ربعا ايه تتوقف هذه
الاضاءه بدلا من الثانيه فجرا الهدف كما
قالت لجنه الشانزليزيه التي تضم جهات
اقتصاديه وثقافيه هو تخفيض استهلاك
الكهرباء في الشانزليزيه خلال عيديه
الميلاد وراس السنه والاسابيع التي
تسبقهما بواقع اربعه واربعين في المئه
وذلك من ضمن خطه لبلديه باريس تهدف الى
تخفيض استهلاك الكهرباء بنسبه 10% لان
فاتوره الكهرباء بالنسبه لبلديه باريس
ارتفعت خلال عام بمقدار
35 مليون يورو لكن التوفير لن يؤثر هنا في
الشانزلي بشكل كبير على الاحتفالات
الميلاد وراس السنه بالمناسبه ميلاد مجيد
سلفا ريما لك ولكل الذي سيحتفلون
جميله واوروبا مضروبه بهذا الشكل انتقل
الى راغده بهنام في بريطانيا كثير من العو
يطفئون التدفئات بالليل همم لتوفير الطاقه
وايضا لتخفيض الفواتير وايضا في باريس
سمعت نفس القصص من
معارف ليه ما الوضع في المانيا
من دون شكري ما الوضع لا يختلف في المانيا
الكثير من العائلات بطبيعه الحال تتجنب
بان تستخدم التدفئه داخل المنازل همم يعني
بالشكل الذي كانت تستخدمه العام الماضي
على الاقل اليوم كان يقول وزير الاقتصاد
رابتها بك بانه هو اراد ان يشكر الالمان
لانه قال لانه
نداءات السياسيين المتكرره باستخدام يعني
الغاز او يعني التدفئه المياه الدافئه
بشكل اقل واقل بانه بالفعل الاستخدام هذا
العام مقارنه بالعام الذي سبق كان اقل
لذلك اريد ان اشكر الالمان على تعاونهم
الاسبوع الماضي كان هناك مخاوف كثيره في
الواقع همم من ان يكون هناك ازمه غاز
حقيقيه هذا الشتاء لانه مرت على المانيا
اسبوع تقريبا بارد يعني كبير جدا بدنا
نحفظ الدرجات الحراره الى 10 تحت الصفر في
بعض المناطق واكثر وتم استخدام التدفئه في
هذا الاسبوع بشكل كبير وكان هناك تحذيرات
يعني من لا يمكننا ان نستمر بهذا الشكل في
شهري اا في شهرين المقبلين يناير وفبراير
وبانه يجب ان نحفظ هذا الاستهلاك اكثر
الان هدات هذه الموجه وانخفض هذا
الاستخدام ولكن المخاوف ريما تبقى من ان
تعود هذه الموجه في الاشهر المقبله ويعود
استخدام الغاز بشكل كبير سؤال سريع
لثلاثه مراسلين ابدا بمصطفى زاروا الكثير
من السياح العرب يقصدون بريطانيا وفرنسا
بدرجه اولى في اعياد الميلاد وراس السنه
وايضا ربما المانيا بريطانيا كيف سيكون
وضع هيثرو ونحن امام اسبوعين يعني صاخبين
همم ثلاث اسابيع صاخبه بالاضطرابات
هناك اربعه ايام اضراب لقوات حفظ الحدود
وايضا الذين يشرفون على الجوازات في في ست
مطارات هي في حقيقه في ست مطارات ما يعني
ان ممكن استخدام مطارات اخرى مثل المطار
هيثرو ومطار قصرك سيضربون يعني ضباط
الحدود خلال هذه الايام ولكن هناك مطار
نيوتن مطار ستاند ايضا يمكن استخدامه
والرساله هو ان اا يجب ان لا يغير
المسافرون همم رحلاتهم خصوصا ان خطوط
الطيران لم تغير جداول رحلاتها طيب خلال
هذه الفتره ولكن هناك توقعات بان يكون
تكون الجوله الثانيه من الاضراباته هي
الاسواق ابتداء من 28 من هذا الشهر
انه الوقفه على الباسبور كنترول الجوازات
هيسرو قد تكون كارثيه بالنسبه للبعض اذا
كان هناك اضراب همم حرس الحدود همم حسين
هنا المقلق هو ان عمال الشركه الوطنيه
للسكك الحديد اس ان سي اف سيشرعون في
اضراب خلال فتره الميلاد ما سيؤدي الى
الشلل التنقل عبر القطارات في فرنسا عشيه
الميلاد وهو ما سيؤدي الى فوضى كبيره في
محطات القطار الشركه الوطنيه لسكك الحبيب
عرضت تعويضات على كل من يتسبب الاضراب
بالغاء رحلته تعويضات بنسبه 200% بمعنى ان
الذي دفع 50 يورو بطاقه سيعوض عليه ب 100
يورو نتيجه شلال الوضع والغاء رحلته
لارضاء المسافرين الذين ستلغى رحلاتهم
ريماها من تعطيل للسواح والمسافين الى
المانيا في هالمرحله
المانيا معفيه في الواقع في هذه الفتره من
اضرابات لانه كان هناك خطوات اتخذتها
الحكومه قبل الوضع الاسابيع زياده الاجور
وزياده الحد الادنى من الاجور لذلك ربما
المانيه تكون الوجه البديله الان عن فرنسا
وبريطانيا للسياح الذي يريدون ان يقضوا
اعياد ميلاد يعني هو راس السنه في اوروبا
قليله على الشاشه لكن انتم بتكون انتظرتوا
وقت طويل بالبرد والمطر حسين قنيبر مصطفى
ازارو راغده بهنام شكرا دائما
[موسيقى]
في مصر امرت انيابه العامه باحاله الفنانه
منه شلبي محاكمه الجنائيه
لمعاقبتها على ما اسند اليها من احرازها
لماده الحشيش المخدر بقصد التعاطي واستمعت
انياب العمل خمسه شهود على الواقعه وما
توصلت اليه
التحريات وتسجيلات المراقبه في مكان ضبطها
بالاضافه الى نتائج فحص المعمل للمضبوطات
بحوزه الفنانه منه شلبي
[موسيقى]
وجه 30 نائبا من اليمين الاسرائيلي رساله
الى الاتحاد الاوروبي طالب فيها عدم
التدخل فيما وصفوها بشؤون الاسرائيليه في
اعقاب الكشف عن وثيقه سريه تتضمن خطه
اوروبيه لدعم سياسي واقتصادي وقانوني
متكامل للفلسطينيين فيما طالبه وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي المكلف باجتماع
الاقتصادي لتلك الوثيقه الاوروبيه
واقتصاديا على بسط سيطراتهم على المناطق
المصنفه جيم التي تشكل 60% من الضفه
الغربيه المحتله قبل بغضب الاسرائيلي
وترحيب فلسطيني نحن نتحدثنا مع كل دول
العالم لانه لا يمكن القبول بان يبقى
الاحتلال يحاول مناعه فلسطين من البناء
واستخدام المناطق هذا الامر لا يمكن نقود
به وبالتالي يعني العديد من الاراضي
الفلسطينيه
تحاول حكومه الاحتلال السيطره عليها وبناء
وتوسيع المستعمرات الاسطانيه الوثيقه
الواقعه في ست صفحات تتحدث عن قيام
الاتحاد الاوروبي بترسيم خارطه للاراضي في
مناطق جيم والعامل قانونيا على اثبات
ملكيتها الفلسطينيه
ومراقبه النشاط الاثريه الاسرائيلي لانه
احدى ادوات فرض السيطره الاسرائيليه
والعمل من خلال مشاريع ودعم على دمج مناطق
جيم مع مناطق الف تحت السياده الفلسطينيه
وبال خاضعه لسيطره المدنيه الفلسطينيه
فيما اعلى نوع وزير الماليه والوزير في
وزاره الدفاع مودريتش انه سيطلق فور تسليه
المنصب حمله لهدم البناء الفلسطيني في
مناطق جيم ويعمل على ضم الضفه لاسرائيل
هذه هي العلامه الاولى لما ينتظرنا من
توتر ومواجه بين الحكومه الاسرائيلي
العديده مع الدعم الاوروبي والامريكي
للفلسطينيين في منطقه تاسيس في الضفه
الغربيه
اسرائيل ترفض تقليديا اي دور سياسي
لاوروبا في عمليه التسويه وتصر على انفراد
واشنطن في ادارتها رغم انها لم تعد قائمه
منذ سنوات لا تخفي الحكومه الاسرائيليه
اليمنيه المتطرفه وشيكه الولاده انها
ستعمل على ضم الضفه الغربيه المحتله
لاسرائيل وانهاء حل الدولتين على الارض
ويبدو ان العلاقه الفلسطينيه الاسرائيليه
المتفجره الطبيعه ستظل تدور في فلك تعقيد
والتصعيد زياد حلب العربيه الضفه الغربيه
المحتله
هذه واقفه مع ابرز احداث فبراير هذا العام
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الحمد لله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ابراهيم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ختام واخبار المساء الى العناوين
لمواجهه المحتمله
[موسيقى]
وقت اذان المغرب
المتحده تقدم منظومات لاول مره الى
اوكرانيا
[تصفيق]
الدوليه
توعدها بمزيد من العزله
[موسيقى]
الاضرابات وتقنين
شكل الاحتفال بعيد الميلاد في اوروبا هذا
العام
[موسيقى]
انا اعود والقاكم غدا وزميله راويه جاهزه
لكم في نشره العربيه 360 مساء الخير مساء
الخير لك ريما طبعا اهم لفاتنا لليوم
سيكون هذه الزياره المفاجاه